I think we are talking too much about Donald Trump, uh,
in. In Europe and uh.
We should um.
Be prepare ourselves for possible second term, um.
For Donald Trump
by fostering our European competitiveness.
Doing our homework is the best preparation
for possible second term of Donald Trump.
And this includes our capabilities to defend ourselves.
Being an attractive partner on eye level
and it comes to the economic situation and it.
And it comes to a fair burden.
Sharing under the roof of NATO
is the best we can do to be um.
Um. In a good partnership with the United States.
And then it doesn't matter which administration.
If we are attractive,
if we do not have to ask others
because we have capabilities ourselves.
The best way to cooperate.